foreign
Why Don't We Begin right in the action
with a case study could you please tell
the story and I do not know the full
story at all I really just have a prompt
in front of me
and that is the story of a 70 year old
woman who had chronic paranoid
schizophrenia for 53 years
why don't we start there if you wouldn't
mind
I'm gonna actually use her real name
because she gave me permission to use
her real name and the book I call her
Mildred but
her real name is Doris
and Doris had a horrible childhood she
had a lot of PTSD depression other
things at by the time she turned 17 she
was diagnosed with schizophrenia
she had daily hallucinations and
delusions over the ensuing decades she
tried numerous
antipsychotics mood stabilizers
antidepressants and other medicines
none of them worked to stop her symptoms
she slowly but surely gained massive
amounts of weight
and
you know by the time she was 68 she
was miserable I hated herself hated her
life
from the ages of 68 to 70 she tried to
kill herself at least six times and was
hospitalized for those suicide attempts
and at the age of 70 she was referred to
a weight loss clinic at Duke University
where they were using the ketogenic diet
as a weight loss method
and she decided to give it a try for
whatever reason and within two weeks not
only did she begin losing weight
that she spontaneously reported that her
long-standing auditory hallucinations
were going away
within months all of her symptoms of
schizophrenia were in full and complete
remission
within six months she was off all
psychiatric medications and remained in
full and complete remission
Doris went on
to live for another 15 years
she lost 150 pounds so the weight loss
thing was secured but much more
important
she remains symptom-free from symptoms
of schizophrenia she remained off
psychiatric medications
she remained out of psychiatric
hospitals
she never tried to kill herself again
and when I last spoke with her she
actually
said she was happy to be alive
she attributed her
she attributed her recovery primarily to
God that she really felt that it was a
miracle from God
and uh and she asked me to tell her
story far and wide to anyone who would
listen in the hopes that it might help
even one other human being spare the
suffering she endured for decades
sadly Doris passed away this past
January of coveted pneumonia